6 43 it's the start of the holiday
season yeah look at this behind us means
it's time to go check out some sweet
treats oh my gosh bianca holman has the
greatest job in the world today she's
live at ethel m's where the holiday
cactus garden has returned and bianca i
was curious because i think of all these
spiny cactus
do they put these lights up and take
them down every single year
well heather i've learned that the
lights that are around the trunk are
kept up all year but the lights that
kind of go on the branches and things
those are only up during the holiday
season and if you can believe it 28
years they're celebrating this year of
the cactus holiday garden that is here
at ethel ends 40 years here in the
valley and they have every piece of
chocolate you can imagine they've got
mint
milk chocolate dark chocolate uh white
chocolate peanut butter chocolate lisa
y'all have everything here but i know
the pandemic last year y'all made some
changes just to the way your operation
runs yeah absolutely everyone had to
pivot in the year of covid um so the
biggest thing for us was just how do we
still welcome guests in but welcome them
in a way that gives them a taste of
chocolate and one of the things that we
did was oops sorry
we ended up putting cellophane around
all of our chocolates so that you can
still have a taste when you walk in the
door beautiful now it is national
chocolate day and you just don't want to
celebrate by having any just kind of
chocolate milk chocolate that you can
get at the store we want something
premium
ultra exclusive ultra expensive no it's
not that expensive but
it's ultra exclusive i will say this is
something that we brought up for our
40th anniversary and it is single origin
chocolate so it means the cup the cocoa
bean came from one
farm in these countries and has been
kept pure there's only three simple
ingredients in the chocolate bar and you
can really taste the difference in this
so it's really for a connoisseur of
chocolate that's good and again what's
the price point on them these are eight
dollars
yeah yeah great and then also you know
what with the holiday cactus garden you
also have a virtual experience and i
think we got a team member that's going
to be setting that off tell us more you
do so mercedes has always been such a
great supporter she will be emceeing our
event it's not live this year so people
cannot come out on november 5th that
evening but you can buy the creamy bites
and cactus lights kit and participate
via zoom see santa turn on the lights
and then do a chocolate tasting yeah and
also again people looking forward to
that cactus garden it's one way santa
people will be able to take pictures
because he has on his mask people this
is really a staple here in the in the
valley when it comes to the holiday
season it is and even though we're not
back to 100 normal we feel like we're
getting closer santa will not be behind
plexiglass this year so that's good
and the kids can have a little bit more
interaction with them all right
wonderful great things to hear and john
heather i did have another piece of
chocolate it was actually prickly pear
it was really good very unique a fruit
kind of like flavor so i'm eyeing one of
these uh cacao
what is it the cacao bar origin single
origin so i'm i'm eyeing one of those
next so we'll see you know what we can
keep talking about the issues with the
supply chain and how it's hard to mail
packages during the holidays yeah one
solution just rip over to flms you don't
have to send anything you've already got
local buy local and that is good stuff
thank you i appreciate it